welcome everyone to today's meeting of
the licensing board
some housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please take the stairs down to
the reception area and out of the
building to the Green in holy Square
which is the assembly point please do
not use the lifts
officers will assist you and advise when
it is esteemed safe to return to the
council offices
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are any children
present does anyone intend to film the
meeting no
uh would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent I'll take my own advice and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls
oh yeah while the meeting is in progress
apologies for absence item one uh we
have a apologies from councilor
Bainbridge and councilor towning is
there any more
apologies for absence no
are there any Declarations of Interest
thank you okay moving on to agenda item
three minutes of the last licensing
board meeting
please can I have a member propose and
second that the minutes of the licensing
board meeting held on the 13th of June
be approved as a correct record
uh proposer councilor wing and seconded
councilor scoby thank you
a gender item 4 licensing subcommittee
minutes please can I have a member who
attended proposed and second that the
minutes of the licensing board held on
the 9th of June be approved as a correct
record
proposed councilor manners and seconded
councilor driver thank you very much
agenda item five exclusion of public and
press please can I have a member propose
and second that the public and press be
excluded from the meeting for agenda
item 6 7 8 and 9 as it contains exempt
information as defined in paragraph
seven of part one of schedule 12a the
Local Government Act 1972. can I have a
proposer
councilor Rogers proposer and seconded
Linda Wright thank you
sure